In the next few decades, the world as we know
it will change, a lot.
This will of course bring many opportunities...
but also many challenges.
More precisely, most developed countries are
facing such a large threat that their response
may determine, in economic, political and
social terms, which countries succeed and
which fail.
Folks, I'm talking about... population aging,
of the demographic pyramid’s 180-degree
turn.
Yes, I’m sure this isn’t news, that most
of you have already heard about this subject…
however...
Have you stopped to think about this process’s
consequences?
Are your governments doing something about
it?
Have they come up with something like a contingency
plan to face the risks that lie ahead?
Listen up.
(THE WORLD FACING A NEW STAGE)
In about 100 years, our world will have changed
a lot.
It has changed so much that if we could get
a time machine, say for example, Doc's Delorean,
and travel 2 or 3 centuries back in time for
a season… sooner rather than later most
of us, if not all, would want to rush back
home.
We’d be missing loads of things; we’d
be horrified by the day to day; we’d be
forced to work intensely to survive; we’d
be afraid of getting sick, even of not being
able to eat, etc., etc.
But... let's stay on the subject…
The fact is that at the end of the 19th century;
the world’s population surpassed the 1.5
billion person barrier.
And yet… only 100 years later, during the
20th century, the world population had multiplied
by 4 and surpassed 6 billion people.
And of course, considering the enormous speed
with which the world population grew, we can’t
be surprised by the fact that many experts
began to worry about overpopulation.
And don’t think this was just a thing among
mediocre experts, scientists and politicians.
In 1974, a report by the Secretary of State,
Henry Kissinger, urged Richard Nixon’s government
to consider birth control in countries such
as Brazil, India, Mexico, Colombia, Ethiopia
and Thailand as a top priority.
According to the report, the “demographic
explosion” that was taking place posed a
serious threat to the very security of the
United States.
Sure, with so many people consuming resources...
Kissinger thought we were heading towards
a world of scarcity and fierce struggles for
resources.
Have you noticed how Malthusian arguments
come up again and again even though they never
actually happen?
The fact is that while guys like Kissinger
tried to think about how to control the world
population and “influence” their decisions...
a change was already taking place, such a
huge change that it would turn into an entirely
new point in the debate.
In the last 50 years, world fertility has
halved, so much so that nowadays Western governments
no longer think about overpopulation... but
about aging.
Today European countries and even the United
States tend to lose native inhabitants.
Check this out:
In Germany, for example, since 1972 there
have been 5 million more deaths than births.
However, the most extreme case has been that
of Russia, where in just 20 years, between
1991 and 2011, there were 13.13 million more
deaths than births.
Future projections show that in the next 50
years, Europe’s native population will decrease
by around 100 million people.
And not only that... the other effect of this
entire process... is that the world population,
especially that of the most developed countries
is aging at full speed... and that, my friends,
is posing many, many challenges.
Pensions, health care expenses, dependence...
and the question is, how on earth can we finance
this gigantic expense?
To give you an idea of what we’re talking
about, it’s estimated that in many European
countries, the percentage of the population
over 65 years will be of around 40% by the
year 2050.
And one of those most affected countries is,
precisely...
Spain.
Listen up.
(A COUNTRY OF RETIRED PEOPLE?)
Here’s an exercise…
Let’s assume that fertility in Spain and
in the European Union remained within the
rates that they’ve had since the year 2000
and that, in addition, no immigrants arrive.
Do you want to know what would happen?
Well, check out the following graph.
As you can see, the population aged between
18 and 40 years, which is the population that
works the most and the population that has
children, would take a huge dip.
Of course… the number of inhabitants just
a decade later, would follow the same trend.
Folks, Spain is one of the countries that’s
beginning to suffer the most from this demographic
crisis.
( "The demographic crisis is getting worse:
Spain suffers its biggest population loss
in 2017".)
If we take a look at the average number of
children per woman, we can truly understand
what’s going on.
And this is taking into account that the arrival
of immigrants in the last 20 years has boosted
birth rates.
Nowadays 23% of all children born in Spain,
almost 1 in 4, have a foreign mother.
But perhaps... the most important data to
predict what’s going to happen will come
from looking at how the number of people of
working age will evolve.
They, after all, are the ones who generate
the vast majority of resources, both public
and private.
Well, if we assume that there’s no immigration...
in just 30 years the working-age Spanish population
would decrease by 10 million people.... and
according to the projections of the Institute
of Statistics of the Government of Spain...
Spaniards will face this panorama by 2050:
19 million people of working age – of whom
of course not all would work – and almost
22 million children and retirees...
That is, the dependent population would be
greater than the working age population.
We’re talking about Spain, but this scenario
is very similar for most developed countries.
And, as you can imagine, all this has many
consequences.
(THE CONSEQUENCES)
In recent times, there’s been a lot of talk
about the risk of robotization... but perhaps
the most imminent risk that developed economies
have to face is their quick aging process.
At the end of the day, it’s clear that an
aging population has several consequences.
For one, it’s foreseeable that if nothing
changes, public spending will skyrocket to
pay pensions, health care expenses, assistance
and care for the elderly, etc., etc.
("Pension spending increases by 50% in Spain
in ten years".)
And no doubt… this will be very clear to
politicians: the hegemony of retired voters
will be overwhelming.
It’s a matter of votes.
But... at the same time, as we’ve seen,
there are going to be far fewer working-age
people... so the question is: How on earth
are we going to pay for this huge expense?
Will the already high taxes be raised even
more, further damaging the competitiveness
of countries with as many economic problems
as Spain or Italy?
Well... that recipe never works.
Now, at this point I think we need to answer
a mandatory question: what the hell can we
do?
(WE NEED A PLAN)
I know, politicians don’t usually like to
think about the future, especially future
problems
What?
I need to think about problems that will happen
20 years from now and risk losing votes?
No no no.
Let someone else take care of that.
Well, if we don’t want to see headlines
like this, developed countries are going to
need a plan:
("Japan's finance minister tells elderly they
should 'hurry up and die' to help reduce country's
rising welfare bill”.
Daily Mail.
The time to make decisions is now, and countries
that decide to look the other way and do nothing
will face many, many problems in the future.
See, lately, here on VISUALPOLITIK, we've
talked a lot about immigration.
Well, experience tells us that this is a good
way to stop population aging and buy time
to make new reforms.
(“As Australia, Hong Kong, New Zealand and
Singapore have shown, immigration can soften
the blow from rapid aging.”
Changyong Rhee, Director of the Asia-Pacific
Department at the International Monetary)
Yes, despite many politicians’ discourse,
the truth is that developed countries will
need many people to arrive from abroad.
So, folks, instead of thinking about building
walls and closing borders, it would be much
more advisable to start a system that manages
to attract people from outside in an orderly
fashion and facilitates their integration.
Of course, that’s not all.
As public pension systems will almost certainly
become much less generous – because they
won’t have much of a budget -, governments
should also be promoting savings... both from
the governments themselves and from families.
( "Is any Spanish political party warning
citizens of the inexorable cut in their pensions?
No, they’re all silent about our true future,
giving a false impression that one doesn’t
need to save to guarantee a fairly dignified
retirement."
Juan Ramón Rallo, Economist and Director
of the Juan de Mariana Institute)
And along with all this, of course, governments
should promote policies that attract companies,
that promote entrepreneurship and above all,
that favor productivity, investment in machines
and technology, and in research and development.
Yes, I think robots will greatly help us with
this problem.
Unfortunately, in many of the affected countries,
including Spain, nothing is being done.
And, finally, before we finish, I’d like
to throw out an idea.
See, the effect of aging is accompanied by
a longevity effect.
Allow me to explain this: thanks to medical
advances, better nutrition and a higher quality
of life, mortality rates for all ages have
decreased.
That is, people are younger for longer.
See, in the United States, for example, a
75-year-old person has the same mortality
rate today as a 65-year-old in the 1950s.
In Japan, 80 is the new 65.
And also, thanks to medical and technological
advances, this evolution continues to grow
and grow.
Which is fantastic.
Therefore... if people now have a longer and
more productive life, wouldn’t it be wise
to encourage them to continue working for
longer, even partially or in more comfortable
roles?
I’ll leave that there.
But now it's your turn...
Would you be in favor of increasing your country’s
retirement age?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.